it's that time again to talk to you
about the latest games in new releases
and this week Shenron brings you into a
world filled with turmoil and alternate
timelines and it's up to you trunks Goku
and friends to save the world and dragon
ball xenoverse you'll be fighting
memorable characters like the ginyu
force and Frieza and even take on the
grade 8 Vegeta and grade it nappa at the
same time you can actually swing them
around by their tails for massive damage
it's going to be a hell of a fight
explore the mysterious toka toka city
starting on the twenty-fourth also this
week we get a real time strategy game
brought to life by none other than the
great Wil Wheaton alongside the voice
talents of Ashly Burch laura bailey and
other kindred spirits use your voice to
command your troops in XCOM esque battle
sequences but with more like a Tron
color scheme and a fantastic soundtrack
by big giant circles gain your tactical
advantage on the 24th this week the
second expansion for dynasty warriors 8
makes its way to North America set
within China's Three Kingdoms period you
basically find yourself in a battlefield
taking down hordes and hordes of enemy
warriors to quench your thirst for blood
but if you're not really into the whole
blood loss thing you can play a role in
the government exercising diplomacy and
peace within nations with a secret love
of murder and blood find victory your
way on the 24th
legendary space RTS returns this week
with homeworld remastered originally
released in 1999 Visser master allows
you to control your fleet and build an
armada across more than 30 single-player
missions but now with graphics your
high-end video card and 4k monitor would
be proud of just to be clear though this
does not include cataclysm start your
trek home across the stars on the 25th
finally resident evil revelations 2
episode 1 is making its debut this
episodic survival horror game is the
tenth installment in the resident evil
franchise and any fans of that franchise
might remember a guy from Raccoon City
called Barry Burton well he's back and
searching for his missing daughter Moira
what waits for him along the shores of
this creepy land no one knows but lucky
for us manly Barry Burton will be there
that's all we need to know be the Burton
on the 25th for further details visit
gamespot com release dates are based on
retailer listings and are subject to
change see you next week crazy
where's more